bolton little league is asking the  community for help after most of its  equipment was destroyed in a fire the  league president says they'd stored  about 24 000 worth of gloves helmets and  uniforms in doolittle park they  discovered it was burned when they went  to retrieve it right now they're  scrambling to replace that equipment  before the start of the season which is  only two months from now  well it means the drivers are playing  and not playing  i mean  a lot of kids that you know  come into the store and say when are we  starting again when we start again it's  exciting to them  it's a way to to keep them out of  trouble  about 200 people kids have already  signed up for the upcoming season bold  and little league they don't charge a  registration fee so they are relying on  donations so if you're able to help if  you can help we have a link to do so at  eightnewsnow.com it's really just a  great organization sorry to see that  terry